[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con la agencia
europea del medicamento confirmo un
posible vínculo entre la vacuna
astrazéneca contra el coi 19 con los
casos de coágulos reportados en personas
que recibieron el fármaco en este
contexto las autoridades de reino unido-
recomienda ofrecer vacunas alternativas
a los menores de 30 años
además el contagio de personas vacunadas
hizo surgir nuevos interrogantes nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france24 doctor muy buen día gracias
por estar con nosotros a muchos entonces
les llama la atención esta recomendación
que hace reino unido- uno creería que al
menos en comparación con los adultos
mayores los menores de 30 años son un
sector de la población menos propenso a
presentar problemas en la coagulación en
la circulación de la sangre cuál sería
el fundamento médico para dar entonces
unas alternativas de vacunas a menores
de 30 años
es importante recordar que los menores
de 30 años especialmente mujeres que fue
lo que se describió en los casos de
trombos toma nunca anticonceptivos
orales y los anticonceptivos hacen que
las personas sean muy propensas a o sean
propensas a generar estos trombos
entonces cuando se segmente esta
población es para que ese factor de
riesgo también se disminuya y en esta
población solución alternativas como las
vacunas de plataformas de acción
nucleicos o proteicas o unas de virus
inactivos otra variada con las que se
pone sale una población joven y esa
estrategia que tomó el reino unido-
doctor una inquietud que surge es la
siguiente corren algún riesgo de los
menores de 30 años vacunados con una
vacuna de astrazéneca además que les
diría a quienes están preocupados por
esto
y la causa de la trombosis no está
específica y no se encontraron factores
de riesgo lo que se encontró fue que era
más frecuente en mujeres y menores de 60
años como muchas de ellas toman
anticonceptivos orales que también tiene
un efecto por otro motivo por eso es que
se llama la atención a que en esa
población se buscan alternativas
distintas a la vacuna de astrazéneca sin
embargo las otras vacunas han mostrado
los estudios clínicos de efectividad y
seguridad y por eso se van a utilizar
varias plataformas de vacunas en varios
grupos de población incluyendo la
población joven ahora algunos casos han
puesto en el centro de la atención en
los últimos días qué sucede con los
contagios en personas ya vacunadas por
un lado el caso del presidente de
argentina alberto fernández que se
contagió y había recibido su segunda
dosis en febrero y por otro lado los
médicos peruanos contagiados los que
están más complicados también ya habían
recibido una sola dosis se abren varias
preguntas además a partir de cuándo
empieza entonces a generarse
los anticuerpos una vez se ha vacunado
los anticuerpos generan desde que se
inicia la vacunación pero un concepto de
vacunación y otro concepto es
inmunización una persona puede iniciar
su vacunación pero estar inmunizadas es
decir perfectamente su inmunidad
establecida que eso se busca en la
segunda semana de la segunda dosis es
decir que mientras está en el proceso de
vacunación puede ser susceptible al
inicio lo que sucedió en la en el
presidente argentino que es que presentó
la infección no necesariamente una
enfermedad por cody porque recordemos
que la vacuna previene efectivamente y
100% es la mortalidad no que no haya
presencia del virus aquí es importante
aclarar que esta persona puede tener
código pero no va a tener complicaciones
por in code usted doctor hablaba de
conceptos y hay dos vinculados a las
vacunas que son muy importantes y es
fundamental distinguirlos porque a veces
se asocian eficacia y efectividad podría
explicarnos entonces cada concepto
y la eficacia se ni en los estudios
clínicos para saber el grupo que recibió
placebo qué eficacia tuvo la vacuna con
respecto a los que sí recibieron la
vacunación la efectividad se hace los
estudios en las poblaciones en millones
de personas vacunadas para ver si ese
concepto de efectividad se replica
cuando la vacunación es masiva lo que
hemos encontrado es que si son similares
la efectiva ineficacia en algunas
plataformas según los estudios de israel
pero es importante y fundamental que el
principal desde el gas es evitar la
mortalidad por hoy 19 las personas ya
vacunadas bueno autor muchísimas gracias
entonces por estar aquí con nosotros en
francia 24 como siempre que tenga usted
un feliz resto de día ustedes también
gracias por siempre acompañaron en cinco
minutos con
[Música]